diese bild von elke daniela aus rumänien
hat elke aus bayern gepflegt bis zum tod
wie ich sie der patientin nicht von der
seite
und für mich elke bleib immer und im
kopf rund um die uhr war sie für elke da
auch nachts hat die rumänen die schwer
kranke frau gepflegt
jetzt müsst ihr sein zwei oder drei
mitarbeiter mindestens zwei ich war nur
und nur sechs stunden pro tag bezahlt
wie viel sie tatsächlich gearbeitet
führen uns waltz ich total walther
steinfelder hatte seiner schwer kranken
schwester elke versprochen dass sie zu
hause sterben dürfe er selbst konnte sie
nicht pflegen nach einem autounfall
brauchte er die hilfe von daniela pankow
dieser engel was die schwestern auch
dort das ist der wahnsinn
mit so einer hingabe und besser kann man
keinen menschen pflegen mit dieses
braucht trifft
seine schwester elke hatte den höchsten
pflege grad 5 sie litt unter multiple
sklerose brust krebs im endstadium und
epileptischen anfällen
das je nach sechs stunden kein
feierabend sein konnte war schnell klar
die rumänische pflegerin daniela pankow
wohnte im zimmer nebenan patientin enkel
konnte per notfallknopf die pflegekraft
jederzeit zu sich rufen auch nachts in
den wochen vor dem tod der patientin
nicht die rumänen kaum noch von ihrer
seite schließt sogar neben dem
krankenbett
sie muss jederzeit wenn es klingelt muss
wir angerannt kommen
das ist arbeitszeit arbeits zeit muss
bezahlt werden also es ist bereitschaft
und es ist zu bezahlen der arbeitszeit
daniela pankow zeigt uns ihren
arbeitsvertrag ein pflegedienst aus
bayern seid ihr 1800 euro für sechs
arbeitsstunden pro tag
die soll die rumänen von montag bis
sonntag verteilen
beginn und ende eigenverantwortlich
einteilen
aber wie soll das gehen die familie
glaubt sie habe beim pflegedienst eine
24 stunden pflege beauftragt bei uns
warum konnten die zweite person das ihm
uns kaufen kann ja die verpackung macht
das schon bibelstunden machen
der pflegedienst bestreitet die anrufe
und der bruder den vorwurf die
hilfsbereitschaft der rumänen ausgenutzt
zu haben weil es in den 2 ich konnte ja
nicht meine schwester in konflikten
lassen ich brauche ja wie
um die arbeitskraft der rumänen auf mehr
als sechs stunden zu verteilen gibt es
mehrere verträge der bruder schließt mit
dem pflegedienst einen pflegevertrag der
pflegedienst mit der rumänen einen
arbeitsvertrag aber nur für sechs
stunden pro tag für den rest der zeit
empfiehlt der pflegedienst einen dritten
vertrag wohnen für hilfe
darin verpflichtet sich die rumänen
gegenüber der familie außerhalb ihrer
regulären arbeitszeit zu noch mehr
pflege gegen freie kost und logis
offenbar wusste der pflegedienst dass
viel mehr arbeit anfällt als im
arbeitsvertrag vereinbart war
die sache ist so der pflegedienst weiß
was dort abläuft der pflegedienst hat
das organisiert der hat denen diese
person zur verfügung gestellt und ihm
war völlig klar dass sie für die leute
dort praktisch 24 stunden zur verfügung
steht das hat er organisiert
arbeitsgericht münchen
daniela pankow verklagt ihren
arbeitgeber der soll ja auch all die
überstunden bezahlen schließlich gilt
auch für ausländische pflegekräfte
deutsches arbeitsrecht ihr arbeitgeber
der pflegedienst ist der meinung seine
mitarbeiterin hätte sich an ihren
arbeitsvertrag halten und nach sechs
stunden feierabend machen müssen
hilfe aus schlagen statt weiter zu
helfen ich glaube aber das ist halt
schwierig wird bei einem menschen im
zweifel pflegebedürftig ist in das
auszuschlagen wenn man dort wohnt
pflegeexperten schätzen bis zu 700.000
osteuropäerinnen in der 24 stunden
pflege ohne frauen wie daniela pankow
würde die häusliche pflege
zusammenbrechen
die betreuungskräfte aus osteuropa
bilden wie so eine dritte säule des
pflegesystems in deutschland und
trotzdem bleiben sie so sind sie
regelrecht ausgebeutet und bleiben sie
unter dem radar
und so müssen gerichte klären was die
bundesregierung bisher in allen pflege
reformen versäumt hat den arbeitsalltag
der 24 stunden kräfte zu regeln
das lehnen wir sind auch menschen wir
kommen hier arbeiten aber es sich normal
seien auch bezahlt richtig die pflege
zentrale wagner in bayern der arbeit
geber von daniela pankow draußen werbung
für 24 stunden pflege drinnen die
nachfrage ob das wirklich so gemeint ist
der familie aber suggeriert das ist rund
um die uhr gibt zu es ist hat welche
probleme wir haben auf der website ist
schlagen geändert da steht mehr stunden
pflege darf wir haben den gestrigen
anfangs auch gewählt weil wir uns sonst
nicht findet weil jeder der so was will
er gibt 24 stunden pflege ein auf eine
24 stunden pflege hatte auch die familie
der schwerkranken elke gehofft
schließlich hatte auch der medizinische
dienst bayern in seinem gutachten
notiert es müsse durchgehend jemand den
ruf nähe der patienten seien auch
mehrmals nachts der pflegedienst kannte
das gutachten
wie kann denn eine kraft reichen
natürlich könnte ich auch sagen
eigentlich 38 schon auch schon oft
stimmt aber haben es diesmal hoch her
hätten wir dann bei 15.000 im monat und
das zahlt ein amt nicht sie sondern dann
müsste es doch günter wagner zeigt uns
was er im monat mit kasse und sozialamt
abgerechnet hat 4311 euro das geld aus
der pflegeversicherung reiche einfach
nie für eine 24 stunden versorgung das
sind naja im inneren fehler im system
die pflegeversicherung wurde immer nur
eingeführt wenn senioren herr blüm
teilkaskoversicherung
das heißt was bei mdk feststellt und was
wir dann machen ist nie der folie bedarf
nimmt man immer nur ein teil der rest
müsste der patient draufzahlen
draufzahlen das gilt derzeit oft nur für
pflegekräfte aus osteuropa
auch sabrina die aus bulgarien musste in
deutschland deutlich länger arbeiten als
in ihrem vertrag stand
die frauen von osteuropa bekommen
weniger geld sie zahlen weniger geld für
diese frauen von aus europa
2015 und 16 hat er die bulgaren in
berlin eine 96-jährige versorgt für
knapp 1000 euro im monat nachts musste
sie die zimmertür offen lassen damit sie
jederzeit das rufen der alten dame hören
konnte sie haben von mir erwartet dass
ich koche einkaufen putzen waschen
bügeln sie überall hin begleitet
ich war immer auf abruf immer in der
wohnung oder bei der patientin
ich habe da auch gegessen und geschlafen
hunderttausende osteuropäerinnen
arbeiten in deutschland rund um die uhr
werden aber nicht so bezahlt auch dobry
na.de hat ihren arbeitgeber deshalb
verklagt ich will das system verändern
damit dass gleichberechtigung zwischen
angestellten in deutschland also
deutschen und uns gibt und wie die
gleichen gehälter bekommen schließlich
kümmern wir uns um ihre eltern und
arbeiten viel länger als sie in eine
arbeitsschicht ein deutsches gericht
urteilte die bulgaren hat nicht nur
sechs sondern 21 stunden pro tag
gearbeitet
ihr arbeitgeber muss fast 40.000 euro
nachzahlen
im juni will das bundesarbeitsgericht
entscheiden ob das urteil bestand hat
zurück nach deutschland pflegerin
daniela pankow meldet sich aus der pause
ein urteil in ihrem fall steht noch aus
wie die antwort auf die frage wie sie
vereinbarte arbeitszeiten einhalten kann
wenn hilfe ständig nötig ist wird das
gericht ihre überstunden anerkennen
inzwischen arbeitet daniela pankow für
einen neuen pflegedienst in münchen
sie wohnt in einer eigenen kleinen
wohnung am wochenende hat sie frei und
nachts da klingeln keine patienten mehr
nach ihr
[Musik]